permettez moi que vous présentez le
prodigieux nikola tesla
le plus grands inventeurs de tous les
temps si vous recherchez nikola tesla
sur google vous aurez 34 millions de
résultat ce sont toujours les quatre
mêmes photos en dehors de ça les autres
images sans plus étranges et créative et
maintenant j'ai le plaisir de vous
présenter un nouveau système de
distribution d'énergie
le courant alternatif vous travailler de
nuit dans un laboratoire secret vous
envoyez des éclairs depuis la terre vers
le ciel alternatif est une perte de
temps
c'est très peu pratique et dangereux
vous avez du feu
[Musique]
va transformer la façon dont le monde
fonctionne vous vivez dans votre tête ce
n'est pas le cas de tout le monde
[Musique]
le monde dans lequel on vit
est un rêve que nikola tesla à rêver en
premier
[Musique]
mes rêves sont déjà réalité